thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a trash
talk and wild ride with steva we got
Chael son and he's like the original OG
trash talker of the UFC and man is he
open about his cheating with
performance-enhancing drugs he'll just
come out and tell you everything about
I mean there the guy's an open book it's
so fascinating talking to him and uh man
there's nothing that he won't talk about
it's like dude it's juicy it's crazy and
let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen shail Sonnen yeah
dude all right look at you look at you
made it your little idea looks like it
worked out huh it's very cool man thank
you go on TV do some crazy stuff
something called the internet and here
we are yeah it's not unlike what you've
been doing where you've got your own
hustle your your own livelihood and
everything and and uh you're killing
them we love your content
um You Met My co-host Scott Randall yes
yes oh he's Scott chale over here and
our new co-host Vinnie what's up dude
nice to meet you oh you're holding the
mic am I taking it am I supposed to be
in the store yeah yeah you're absolutely
supposed to be in the spot what do you
think of these these all right I think
they're great I'm new to them why don't
you wear them on camera I well I'm new
to them and some people teased me online
they said that I look like a guy named
bubbles from uh yes like a South Park or
something and I wrote them back and said
is that is that good or bad or you know
I can tell just by looking at them from
here that they're pretty heavy
prescriptions yeah I went in to get my
eyes checked and right just right over
here as a matter of fact and they said
there's we can't help you they said you
got to go down to Rite Aid you got to
get something called readers I said what
are those they said look they're right
they're right up front go to any
drugstore so I got the glasses and my
wife helped me picked out the lenses
that's a very personal decision when
you're gonna you know you're changing
the whole look of how you're gonna
forever I know I like it thank you buddy
I like it you would tell me right now
yeah that's great I wear glasses I think
it's cool
um if Lasik was an option that would
work for me and make my eyes 20 20. I
kinda still like the glasses sure yeah
it's on brand for you you know I mean I
guess I don't know sometimes I want to
wear them sometimes I don't but yeah um
so we're here in
the Mean Streets of Westland Oregon
how mean is it it's pretty rough yeah
you saw around here yeah it's bad I'm
surprised you guys can't I really
thought this was it I thought it was a
gag I even made a video as I was coming
I've been catfished twice I got
catfished by a girl named Aspen lad I
got catfished by this uh Hollywood
producer so a female and I was gonna do
this Clint Eastwood movie and I had to
do this love scene with her over the
phone I had to make kissy noises to her
this was part of the catfish and then
you know pretty soon it's hey send 5000
a Bitcoin over here your kissy voice
goes out oh wow and so
might be catfishing me so I actually
filmed this I pulled up and turned into
the great big bus with you guys yeah
this is cool man
um I want to come to you guys by the way
this was nice of you to drive all the
way to little me ah man we we it's
important to us to make that make it
convenient for the guests that's why
it's a mobile operation
um Aspen lad UFC fighter recently
released from the UFC
oh you got right she missed weight and I
want to say four times yeah I know three
but I want to say four ended up in the
pfl had a big debut and she just won and
I'm acting like World friends because I
thought we were then I found it it's not
even her she might not even know I exist
but I've got like years of of DMS going
back and forth with her yeah and then
the person actually comes out and goes
hey by the way you know I just work for
her like just so you know well I
appreciate that that's not quite a
catfish it's in the ballpark what do you
think of kissy face a kissy face is a
catfish
uh well the catfish is more like some
somebody pretending to be somebody else
right and then you go and meet this
person and it's someone completely oh
you have to meet for it to be a catfish
you have to mean all right because kissy
face and it gets just get me you know
Bill Goldberg the pro wrestler yeah he
was also so it's like a collage of Bill
and I doing them kissy face with her
okay I thought you guys would have heard
of this I think it's gonna be fun like
oh Chandler's gonna bring this up now I
feel like a fool that I brought it up no
dude I should have stayed on the glasses
routine you're not uh you're not a fool
at all
um you're actually like shockingly
articulate and educated it's it's it's
almost wildly counter-intuitive that
you're a fighter when you're so well
spoken and it's great like you went to
University of Oregon yes about two hours
that way yeah put in perspective for you
so you know our state a good student
yeah yeah yeah I like school yeah I was
on the pursuit of knowledge I thought
like it was important to you know get
certified smart by somebody and yeah I
paid my dues in the whole bit but I went
back on it now I mean I you know I don't
know I've got a little bit of a battle
with uh I've got a little bit of better
with uh higher education I will be
governor of this state someday but that
will be part of my platform we've been
praising the people that go to the
school long enough pretty soon when you
start praising the folks that built the
school I feel like those are uh kind of
the unsung heroes around here I mean a
lot of changes when old jail takes over
it's gonna be a lot sooner than you
think by the way I like it I like it I
did you go to to the University of
Oregon on a wrestling scholarship yes
yeah they had a wrestle great program we
had uh Oregon where I went Oregon state
was our big rival Portland State I mean
that was just within Oregon they've
dropped them all Boise State they had it
uh just on the other side of the UC
Davis where Uriah Faber went just bikes
up they dropped them all we have Oregon
State still Chris Pendleton's come in
but uh wrestling's under attack when I
was there though in the 90s uh it was
still big and still a lot of opportunity
for guys not now though exactly why is
that you know it's a hard Sport and it's
very respected by people but the guys in
the sport do not speak up they don't
demand anything they won't ask for money
uh coaches aren't paid uh and that goes
all the way to the Grassroots and the
smallest of levels all the clubs it's
it's kind of known as a poor man sport
which I think there's a lot of Honor in
that but the other side of it is when
it's time to speak up but it is all
about money wrestling never has any they
never ever need to chip in and they're
the first ones to get the ax
yeah because not a lot of people go to
watch a wrestling event that's right
this is like basketball or that's right
I love wrestling I wrestled here uh
coached here I complain every time they
cut a program and to your point in the
meanwhile I don't go to the events I
don't I don't kick in I throw a big fit
every time they get ready to cut a
program because there's there's no
attendance but in the meantime I don't
buy a t-shirt so you know I'm as guilty
as anybody else I suppose what do you
think the solution is for that then
well I think what Jiu Jitsu has done
Nationwide has been fascinating I mean
just the numbers that they're bringing
in it's it's the same people
um but there is a financial element to
it there is a cleanliness element to it
there is a uniform element to it
um and then when it's time to compete
there's a lot of lights and cameras as
well you know wrestling can't get on the
front page but the coaches don't even
dress like front page news they don't
belong there they put a wrestling mat
out in 10 chairs on each side who wants
to go to that where's the cheerleaders
where's the beers where's the nachos I
feel like you know could be a level of
excitement
is uh Brazilian Jiu Jitsu part of uh
Collegiate programs no no it's not but I
mean it is those same guys and they
played UNLV this year for Abu Dhabi for
uh the championship in fact Dana White
bought the rights to Tabu Dhabi for the
next one they announced that yesterday
it's a big deal UFC Fight Pass is making
a massive commitment into into grappling
okay good can I ask you what a very
guilty look on your face
what I think might be a sensitive
question perhaps a personal question did
you watch the premiere of powerslap yeah
okay and you're right that is a tough
one yeah where do you go on that and
maybe you could give me some guidance
um
I I no I did not but I feel as though I
did I I read all about it I saw the
replays and then uh surprisingly to me
is apparently they have competition
there's somebody else in Vegas uh doing
a slap League they they made it to TV
about a week before Dana did they were
in a cage I mean I thought it was Dana's
project but it's not
um and my only point is I didn't know
that there was room for two I didn't
know there was room for three I know
there was room for one
I want to be very open to it I really do
I've never seen a football game or a
hockey game I know they are but I've
never watched a full one and I would
like to have more hobbies and maybe that
slap is one of them so I have an open
mind but I don't know how they're going
to convince me there's a sport going on
if you let the person hit you right I'm
open to it but I think they're gonna
have a hard time they're gonna have a
hard time with me well it's weird
because like when you're watching UFC
one two three you're like oh [__] this
is going to be huge like you know it's
gonna be huge and then I saw the TBS
commercial and you're like how is this
how why are they getting behind this
like how is how does this have legs
really really weird to me I I struggle
with it as well
um and and
I remember when jackass came out or when
it was gonna come out I remember
thinking yeah there there's uh
this is something that that would
resonate what we're doing it's wild it's
crazy I think I can picture it being
really popular the problem that I
envisioned us having is just being
allowed on TV sure you know like uh that
nobody's gonna love nobody's gonna show
what we do we became rather Nimble and
working our way around the rules and
kind of jumping through hoops and a
little bit we found ways to get away
with showing what what we do
I don't know how this is on TV sure it's
not one of the same thing and you know
so it's already done everything that
we're seeing is already done they're
acting as though they're just presenting
this but it's in the key and I only
point that out because you know they've
got a live audience there or or even the
the officials that were overseeing are
those are the same guys that you see
overseeing the Octagon right you know
because it is the Nevada State athletic
so they apply the officials and there
was just there was a lot of support
there that I I think is helpful but I
think it still does come down to why are
you guys why are you letting the guy hit
you why are you letting him hit you
right I've never driven around town and
seen a studio where it's how you come in
and sign up and I've never met a guy
that goes I'm a coach and I teach people
to slap by that
you don't have that sacrifice to me I
don't I don't know that you're a sport
right the the point I was making before
about how I pictured jackass being
popular but I was having trouble getting
on TV
it
I I don't I I don't necessarily
feel like power slap is even like maybe
it is popular but there's something that
about like what what we did that was
kind of cute silly clever you know as
well as dangerous sure and the slap
thing just doesn't feel like it's that
you know like I I love a great you know
wild and crazy thing and I I I struggle
with it I think it's good and short form
like like a nice Tick Tock clip with
somebody getting slapped and knocked out
but I don't think long form 30 minutes
yeah whenever I saw it before it was
always just looked like a backyard
wrestling operation yeah kid like like
it's guys that that that are doing it on
their own it's like oh what are they
doing but they're crazy and like they're
just kind of like you know in a uh
official capacity in a like regulated
format it it just it feels but I'm very
interested to see like how it performs
on a commercial level for sure and I
will tell you this I
have been more inundated whether it was
Clips online or the conversation we're
having now uh with slap than I ever have
been with bare knuckle just by example
okay bare knuckles got this great
production they're paying good money
they're bringing in uh very nice crowds
uh
but I I belong to a gym I belong to an
MMA gym I've had teammates Paige VanZant
by example that's going to do bare
knuckle we're not in the Saun after
practice talking about bare knuckle
fighting but everywhere I go they are
talking about slap and I don't know you
know how that translates if that's a
good thing it's a bad thing but there
seems to be something at least ripe for
the taking if Dana can grab those stores
and there is a story to tell and he's a
masterful Storyteller if he can get us
enveloped uh he's gonna have something
here but the action itself that's not
going to do it and I think a cage fight
does I think you could watch a cage
fight on mute and understand what's
going on I think we're gonna need it
we're gonna need a story why are you
guys here what brought us here and why
are we right why are we doing this it's
very well put
um
to talk to us about your uh your your
YouTube how many people are you are
involved in the the production of the
channel channel on YouTube sure we have
uh four people my my partner Ryan is in
California and I got a little studio
just uh right over here about half mile
away with the bad guy coffee yeah yeah
that's right yeah
okay I appreciate you knowing that
though and then we have two two folks
that come in the studio along with me to
help produce it and edit it and uh I
never thought I would be doing that I
mean I must tell you like I can remember
being in first grade and freshman year
in high school and they that very first
day of teacher said what do you want to
be when you grow up and I would always
write president of the United States but
I never would say I wanted to be a
personality on YouTube or I want to be
sitting in Dutch Brothers talking you
know visiting with Stevo uh it just
wasn't a thing that wasn't the internet
wasn't a thing or YouTube and so I I
really do feel very fortunate about that
because I enjoy participating I like to
talk about it and in this particular
sport if you're not in there throwing
the punches in the kicks it's very hard
to participate so uh I do feel like yeah
to be able to announce or talk about the
other guys because I'm still a fan you
know my competitive time left but my
time in the sport hasn't left but you
because because you have the studio here
but then I feel like when you're on the
road you just get in a hotel room and
start going that's right so my partner
flies in and yeah we'll we'll convert a
room I'll stay somewhere he'll stay
somewhere we'll get a third room and
turn it into the studio for a week how
cool is that and like uh how quick and
easy is that it's so fresh in your head
that you just get right into your hotel
room and start talking about the fight I
think it's great to go right after and
our numbers are totally different too
you know if you if the fight ends and we
can get right to the market if we wait a
day and we used to do that we used to
Sunday was off and then you come in on
Monday but our numbers would be I mean
we do uh 80 000 on one eight hundred
thousand on the other you know it was
that big if you could be the first to
the market which is why we had the
studio so we come right from right from
the arena pop in the room and try to get
it uploaded yeah yeah I love it I mean
it's a game right some people I don't
think they show a lot of respect if you
have a successful YouTube channel people
think oh that just happens like well no
there's actually a lot that goes into it
yeah there's a lot a lot that goes into
getting that uh to the audience same
with Michael Bisping too like his
channel is great and it's like yeah it's
my go-to for UFC news you and my and
Michael bisbing thank you for that he's
killing it I watch Michael's stuff every
day too yeah he mixes it up and he does
some fun stuff too
um why are you out I with if Jake Paul
fights Fury okay because I don't think
I don't think in the audience the boxing
Community has set Jacob uh to very large
extents I mean they already did this
once they told him go fight Fury now
they didn't want to see the fight and
they full well knew that if he went and
had the fight they were going to take
the credit from him and say oh this
guy's never fine but in the top 10 and
he's not a real boxer and Fury's got a
combined record all of his opponents
combined I can't remember but it's
something like nine wins against 125
losses it was absolutely insane if you
go and take the six guys that he bought
that's well and good but the community
told Jake to do the fight they're
telling him this is the one we'll get
behind let's encourage it the old man's
uh character his brother Tyson's the
most respected guy and they're just
setting him up for failure and I don't
really feel like coming and telling the
audience to watch this fight that I
don't think fumbles is going to show up
to and moreover it turns out uh that
it's going to be held in Saudi Arabia so
there will be the money for those guys
are going to throw down the yeah the
cash so now it's a lot more likely than
if he was going to come over and do it
at Madison Square Garden on his own but
you know I I'm not comfortable believing
it's gonna happen I don't think the guy
wants to box him you think they can even
sell out Madison Square Garden gonna
know that was Dana White beef of like
he's like yeah it's hard to put on a
fight it is especially that MSG you're
talking about Tommy Fury yeah and that's
the problem I don't think Tommy and Jake
Paul could sell the guard now because
don't forget they've done a million
dollars and it was filling up pretty
nicely and uh they had to refund all the
tickets because because Tommy didn't get
on the plane and come do it so I don't
think you could come and burn that same
Market twice
what about t wood were you were you
shocked when he got knocked out the way
he did I was shocked and it was a hard
hit yes it was the hardest hit I've ever
seen in boxing yeah and then face down
with the butt wipes promos
he's really good Jake Paul and that
pains people to admit I don't know why
but that really people did not want to
give him or his brother credit for being
tough guys but they are they were tough
guys in high school they were all state
wrestlers in Ohio which is a very
competitive State
um and they got into the boxing and they
really shouldn't have had enough time to
be this good even if they were training
twice a day every day four years isn't
that long to be as good as he is to go
out there and beat Anderson Silva for
goodness sakes his brother went the
distance with Floyd I don't care about
that size difference you went you went
30 minutes with Floyd good job
um if for some reason people don't want
to say that about him but see I saw what
you saw he hit him hard he hit T wood
hard he took hard shots in the meanwhile
he's got very good faints people people
don't quite understand how important a
faint is but you can't just get it
you're not born with it sometimes you're
born with power but you're not born with
the ability to to do a movement and get
the other guy to it's like a chess move
right that's right and so you know to
watch him go out and do that you know
while being tired while being attacked
that's it though yeah I know you're
fooling around but that's what it is
my I went to high school with guys that
were jerks that would do that and go two
for Flinch and for some reason I gotta
punch you in the shoulder but that's a
real thing if you can get a guy flinched
you can get t-wood to Flinch and freeze
up so you can come in and land that hook
man Jake deserves credit they they
didn't want to give it to him I could be
wrong but didn't Jake just uh reach out
to Nate Diaz to say he signed with pfl
which is another MMA organization and
that's like the biggest curveball of all
like now Jake Paul's committed to
fighting MMA and he challenged Nate Diaz
to uh two fights one MMA one boxing yeah
yeah yeah which is an interesting thing
and he's on this uh this uh like fighter
advocacy thing like uh what do you what
are you making like a Fighters Union
yeah type deal yeah something along
those lines he hasn't been extremely
clear but yes he wants to have something
for the fighter so they can come in and
they can they can bargain a little more
collectively I know that uh uh medical
benefits are are a huge one I've heard a
number of guys say that and when they do
say it I don't want to tease them like
that seems like a nice thing to want
people to have more I like that but it
does concern me go wait do you guys not
have it because Dana didn't get it for
you like he's your father do you not
have do you guys not know it's at one
phone call and you get set up I do
wonder about that with like Francis
Nagano when he was like yeah that was
one of the things I'm arguing about like
you're making eight million a fight or
whatever that is it's 400 a month for
health insurance like you can't just pay
for the year right it's a simple
question how much do you Value Health
well I value it enough to make sure that
I have my athletic greens every day ag1
from athletic greens the most delicious
comprehensive convenient nutritional
supplement you can get period it's the
best it's got 75 different and vitamins
minerals Whole Food sourced Super Foods
probiotics adaptogens and like I said
delicious you start off your morning
with one scoop in a pint of water and
it's all of your nutrition needs man it
fills in every Gap in your diet plus it
helps with your gut health your
cognitive health
I'm telling you this stuff does it all
and I value it
above everything I value it with my
health because I attribute my health to
it and if you go to athletic greens.com
Stevo they're gonna hook you up dude
with five free travel packs that have
your comprehensive convenient nutrition
for the whole day plus an entire year's
supply of immune boosting vitamin D you
can't beat it it's a deal worth jumping
on athletic greens.com
Stevo and uh man get him to it because
this stuff rules now let's get back to
jail
but I don't know I mean maybe there's
other things in the contract that he
wasn't talking about but like you're
you're a independent contractor yes it's
right it's the blanket statement of
every independent contractor in the
United States very clear that that whole
hangup was about being allowed to box
sure so the health insurance is a real
red herring in that conversation it's uh
got nothing to do with it and by the way
and by the way what what do you predict
there I mean so yes it's about the
boxing match and now Tyson Furies come
out and says I want to do the boxing
match but we don't have a promoter
that's got distribution or or a
pocketbook or a ring for that matter so
so how are they going to do that because
I didn't see a value in angano I saw a
value in the sitting UFC heavyweight
champion with Dana White Carnival Barker
in your corner if you take that out of
it I feel you took the value out Am I
Wrong
um you're not wrong and I think that the
what you're pointing to is is what is so
wrong with uh the Dynamics of boxing
people say about look at how much money
these boxers make and I would stand and
look what happened to the sport because
it's so disorganized and and there isn't
a a promotion that's really that got a
control of it and that's why the UFC is
doing so well I would say that the
biggest problem with uh an engineer Fury
fight
is the fact that and gone who had to
wrestle his way to Victory against Cyril
gone like uh the the Striking wasn't
there against Cyril gone so what's to
make us believe that the Striking is at
the level that's going to make it worth
watching Fury and ingoning yeah I see
that as problematic as well the the fact
and great job too and Gano for having
that weapon that we didn't know we had
turn into that tool digging deep I mean
he deserves a lot of credit for that win
over surreal but I saw that too we're
not talking about surreal versus uh
Tyson and surreal was clearly the better
Striker right so I think that's an
interesting spot and I it does concern
me for Francis I I don't think
because it all comes to Genesis as Conor
McGregor fighting Floyd Mayweather but
some guys seem to be missing Conor
McGregor did not get 100 million to
fight Floyd Mayweather the two divisions
simultaneous Champion with Dana White in
your corner got a hundred million
dollars to box and I I feel that perhaps
Francis is missing that and you know he
sure seems like a gentleman to me
Francis seems like a very nice guy but
this one is uh it's a miss and we don't
know how old he is he's at least 36
years old and that time goes fast now
you gotta bum me on top of it man yeah
you're taking that 8 million in my
opinion you don't know how old he is
yeah what do you mean well he so where
he comes from it's very tough to get
records it's it's very tough and so he's
saying he's 36. he doesn't even know
himself well I I don't he could take a
great uh offense to that I don't want to
go down the road of offending him I'm
just sharing with you he claims to be
36. I'll I'll see that he's at least 36.
he could be older than that though and
I'll tell you in this sport man it it
changes it changes quick you know he was
blessed with with some very beautiful
DNA but it does catch you at some point
at this same time though the last thing
to go is power yep and so heavyweights
are going to last longer than the
lighter guys it sounds like you can just
count the tree rings on those tree trunk
legs sure yeah the
um the real pisser about it though is
that when he did emerge against surreal
as a wrestler that we did not know he
was he became a lot more interesting in
MMA and now he's just a lot black you
know he really wanted to see it but the
the
the evolution continue within Ghana oh
Francis versus Jon Jones I mean for our
entire industry you co-promote any way
that you want to do it that is the
biggest match our industry could could
produce that that was something very
special John taking three years to go
put on the size you know I disagree with
John on that John was saying I need to
weigh 240. saying this but I gotta weigh
240 to beat these heavyweights I think
he could have walked right in their way
in 206 and beaten all those heavyweights
I I don't think that John has ever fully
understood quite how good John is hmm I
was getting ready to I was getting ready
to fight him and I was on a conference
call with him and he was talking about
the things that he had to do to beat me
and he was talking about the things he
had to do to be the best light
heavyweight ever who he was saying was
Tito Ortiz and I'm listening to this
going
there's none of those things that are
true you're going to kill me and you
would kill Tito too and he was like 21.
yeah I'm on my phone yeah that's right
he's a 21 year old kid I gotta go show
him this respect but I knew he was
better than he knew he was I I guess
maybe that's my point and uh I think
that that's one of his strengths I think
the fact that he does still get scared
that he does uh you know still still see
these guys in ways that they could win I
think that's one of the things that
keeps John Sharp but yeah we'll only
have to wonder what would happen if
those two would have fought that'd be a
special night I mean
I wonder if Jon Jones watched Israel out
of Sonya go up to light heavyweight and
just get held down by John blahovich and
think oh I don't want to do that let me
put on somewhere oh it could be you know
I know I know that John shares the
practice room with a lot of very
meaningful heavyweights uh Travis Brown
comes to mind Alice drover and comes to
mind uh Andre arlovsky you know but
these guys were Champions these guys had
real good and and they'll be the first
to tell you you know we we couldn't
really deal with him he moved too well
he was too long so I bring that up
really as a compliment to John I think
that he also burned three good years of
his life I think there's some some real
good moments to have there and I can't
relate I was never I was never good
enough as John I wanted to be world
champion John won so many World
Championships he gave one of them back
he goes here you take it I couldn't
imagine giving one back but uh
I mean that's another level of success
or even Francis to walk away and give a
belt back I couldn't even imagine I was
critical at the time when uh when when
he vacated the belt I I said
um
the the tell for me was that we had seen
so many champ Champs up to that point
the goal is Champ champ sure there's no
nobody ever gave back a bill to be a
single Champion another division sure so
that indicated to me
that uh I don't know it was weird and I
remember too because uh you know we were
out in Albuquerque with Jon Jones you
know and staying at his house and you
know at the at the time he was uh fresh
off of his controversial win over
Dominic Reyes uh he was doing his uh I'm
gonna go save the world with The Care
Project wrong and he invited us out to
be a part of that and um you know he was
really outspoken about you know there's
not enough to pay I want more money
and uh I told him I said I think that
the uh the way to get more money
is
to understand that everybody wants to
see you lose and your last
fights were so so close you know people
even arguing that you didn't win them
that people really believe
now is the chance to see Jon Jones lose
sure that's the leverage you know and uh
to your point three years away yeah
well that's what's keeping the Jake the
Jake Paul uh experiment uh above float
too is that people want to see him get
beat yeah and yeah John would steer into
that just a little bit I think he's got
a very favorable matchup with surreal I
think that uh I really like to know what
happened with Stipe I personally would
just like to see Stipe in there more
Steve a believes he's gonna fight the
winner I I don't know if I'm if I'm
bullish on that you know if you couldn't
get the fight with John now you've
waited 14 months to get it he win if you
can't get it now what's going to be
different six months from now so let's
see how that all plays out but I would
like to leave you guys with one thought
on that which is when Jon left three
years ago he he put you talk about
Burning Bridges he puts he put C4 all
over that bridge he didn't know how to
detonate it but if he would have known
he would have blown that bridge up I
mean he was not coming back and
everything's going to be changing you're
going to give everybody different things
or you'll never see me again
he's now back and with a raise and into
a world title fight Francis was a
gentleman we if we're going to tell the
story accurately we do have to say that
about Francis he never used profanity he
never raised his voice you know Francis
never made any threats and he's a very
intimidating guy and my only point being
if John can come back after what he did
Francis can come back too and if I was
to make a prediction he's going to right
yeah Francis has a rude awakening come
in and I will tell you I don't think he
meant to disrespect Dana White but to
sit down and tell Dana there's problems
with Dana's contract after everything
that Dana did and the way Dana changed
the sport now you're gonna sit down and
you're gonna tell Dana I mean Stephen
let's just change this Dana sits down
with you and tells you how to throw a
jab then he tells you how to throw a
cross and he tells you uh how much you
should be eating and sleeping and you go
well leave the fighting to me you bring
the bells and whistles I'll bring the
action it's like exactly so why are you
telling me how to do the business side
of this you're not going to change my
contracts you're not going to change the
way that I do things
Francis wants to have a meeting before
every single fight he has and I know he
doesn't mean that is rude he thinks
that's a respect but there's not enough
time to have those kind of meetings Dana
puts on 11 fights every single Saturday
it is so disrespectful for you to imply
that we're gonna sit down and talk about
talking we got to get things done
quickly right
and that's just the reality if you don't
understand that you're being rude to me
even if you're not trying to be but you
are
what kind of a time frame do you think
um we can see
the boxing not work as well for Francis
as he hopes it might and for him to come
back to the UFC I'm concerned with that
six months sure that's a great guess so
Tyson Fury came out last night just in
case you guys didn't see this ties of
fear comes out last night he says Hey
Francis and Gano I know that you're no
longer under contract with the UFC so
let's you and me fight and they've
always talked that they're gonna go make
a sport up they're not just going to box
they're not gonna do MMA they're gonna
create something so Tyson laid out what
that is he said we're gonna do it in a
cage we're gonna do a four ounce gloves
it's gonna be Queen Berry rules and Mike
Tyson is going to be the special referee
and it's like okay let's see
I grew up with guys that would ask the
girl out but but then they put LOL hey
we should go to a movie this weekend lol
it's like oh but that's what Tyson's now
done putting Mike Tyson in there as a
special guest referee was laying out a
plan that you'd really like to work but
you're not sure anybody's gonna sign off
on it so then you went too far with it
and I just thought it was psyllium going
Tyson if you can't get this done if you
can't find somebody with distribution
and a platform to to scoop this up this
is a huge miss this is a massive massive
mistake and why are you guys going off
to make out your own sport yeah like
what's on the line your reputation has
got to be on the line or his reputation
it can't be we're doing this for nothing
it's got to be one or the other do
Queens Bears or do unified rules
Queensberry just means western boxing
okay yeah they like to call it
Queensbury if you're a real prick to
show that you're a boxing historian
you'll throw out the term like
Queensbury which is precisely why I just
it just means western boxing okay yeah
man it's really interesting I I hope
that that Scott's right six months I
mean it's like with Dana White's always
trying to plan something or somebody's
like why wants to start their own thing
he's like go for it do you have any idea
how hard it is to start something like I
mean that that documentary three letters
I mean you saw how hard it was to get
the UFC off the ground it's like well
you're just gonna do that now right
um he doesn't know he's being
disrespectful Scott he does Francis
doesn't know he's being a jerk about
this telling Dana we're gonna sit down
and talk before every time I have a
fight Dana's got 556 guys under
contracts he puts on 11 fights every
Saturday there's no one that he can sit
and talk with the hotel before we check
everybody and I can't I'm not going to
talk to you every week the the airplanes
before every plane ticket I'm not gonna
talk to all of them and I can't talk
different I gotta be able to text you I
gotta go be able to do a step further
which is something that Dana did last
night he goes to a press conference and
he announces Glover to share versus uh
Jamal Hill for the light heavyweight
championship he hadn't spoken to those
guys they had never agreed to fight each
other they never agreed to go five
rounds I never agreed it was going to be
a title fight they were going to meet in
Brazil Daniel knew he could count on him
he goes to a press conference he's in a
jam he's got a light heavyweight fight
that goes to a draw that wasn't supposed
to do that he goes and makes an
announcement and they both make the boss
look good that's that's what you do if
you're actually on board Francis wants
to sit down and talk he doesn't know
he's being rude but he is that's
extremely rude and the world doesn't
work that way we don't have time who's
giving him that advice I have the
foggiest idea he dropped his he dropped
his manager he dropped his manager as a
guy with CAA Markell who done a very
good job and then he was getting advice
from many people but he actually handed
it himself which is one of the reasons
this was a problem one of the demands
that Francis made on top of health
insurance he demanded that there be a
fighter Advocate at every meeting like
the one they're having and Dana's
looking around going Francis first I
don't give guys meetings but I'm giving
you one secondly you didn't bring an
advocate you could have brought an
advocate you didn't bring you fired your
advocate so you're telling me to provide
an advocate for all the guys first off
if I provide the guy he's going to be
he's gonna be helping me not you and
secondly why didn't you bring one if
they're so important and that was just a
little bit of the conflict that they ran
into where at some point you're looking
around going man I this isn't worth it
because when I find better you don't and
I would tell you the right guy always
stands out like there's never been an
Olympic Games in in the history of the
world where reach out when I slap Stevo
as we're watching something like I could
have won this year I set this Olympics
out it doesn't work that way there's
never been a World Series we're so well
you know I could have done this I didn't
want to play this year the right guys
will always come forward now number two
and three and five and ten maybe not but
the gold the best will always step
forward and take his credit except for
uh Simone Beals I remember you uh I
loved your takeoffs yes because it was
the truthful
to all the people who worked so hard to
be in the Olympics and then
she's just gonna not compete you yeah
you well the bigger problem is you know
and she was having some mental issues
with that so the rumor goes is that in
America she has a prescription for
Ritalin
Tokyo's who hosted the Olympics and if
you fly in there with ritalin it's it's
a banned substance like we would say
with say cocaine just by example so she
didn't bring her medication and it did
play some tricks on her mind and and I
do believe that I do accept that what
bothered me is where she was being
praised she was taken a bow for the
strength it took strength to stand aside
and put my health in front of sport like
oh my God no it didn't and then I
watched all these other gymnasts that
were worried about taking on Simone so
they also oh hey Bravo somebody was like
no absolutely not that was a weak move
it was a terrible move if you would have
said this a week ago we could have flown
somebody else over that had the
opportunity instead we got all these
girls that are sitting around for
another four years begging for the spot
that you've got and you're there and
you're not gonna make the walk come on
get out of the way yeah I love that can
I ask a question change gears on
wrestling and uh no stick with wrestling
but uh it was Bilal Muhammad just on
Rogan yeah and he was talking about the
dagestani when he went over there to
train
what is the difference between American
wrestling and the the wrestlers in in
Dagestan that are so good I mean what
they wrestle bears
it's cool to wrestle bears but it's not
cool to look like a bear dude come on
you need to have a good clean shave and
you don't need to spend a bunch of extra
money on that that's why I use shaving
products from harrys.com my five blade
German engineered razors they get it
done no lights and and vibrators nothing
it's just what I need and I've been
using it for years I'm never going back
Harry's is how I shave my face and if
you want to go to harrys.com
Stevo man is there a killer deal for you
I feel sorry for the people who don't
take advantage of this offer because
you're gonna get the Truman shave
starter kit with everything you need
five blade razor weighted ergonomic
handle foaming shave gel plus the travel
cover to protect the blades it's
everything you need it's a fifteen
dollar value and they will give it to
you for just three bucks if you go to
harrys.com
Stevo I'm telling you man I got it on
Harry's years ago and I'm never going
back so harrys.com Stevo and let's talk
about these bears
[Music]
because they're a different style
because he's like you they do not let up
every minute every second they will try
to win every match but if you took like
is there is there different styles of
wrestling when it comes to that what do
they do differently that makes them so
good are they that good you know you're
a wrestler you can I mean if you were at
the University and you wrestled somebody
like how would you do with in your Prime
with one of them like what's the
difference I've met in my life and I
used to live at the Olympic Training
Center in my life if I really sat on a
thought I probably met three people and
maybe four that have won an Olympic gold
medal like I met that person and it was
Olympic champion
I was in a sauna in the UFC and there
was a young man in there that nobody had
heard of and his name was khabib
nurmagomedov and he was speaking in the
song and I was just over overhearing him
and he said that he lives in a village
of 2 800 people and of those 2821 our
Olympic gold medalists and he lives in
Dagestan and so I was much like you what
are you talking about 21 Olympic
champions in this little village how
could this possibly be true and we do
have a different style in America like
what you'll know is folk style or
Collegiate what we do in the NCAA is not
what's contested in the Olympic Games uh
that's International wrestling freestyle
Greco-Roman that's all they do in
Dagestan and nobody fully understands
why they're so successful as a region uh
most of the boys do go into it it's um
funded by the government and it's very
important by powerful countries to win a
whole bunch of medals uh because you're
you're showing the the power of your
military if you're athletes who are
overseen by government who are trained
who are if your athletes can't why would
your military it's the exact same thing
you've either got good leaders or you
don't so when you see people like the US
where you'll see Trump actually show up
to the Olympics or Obama show up to the
Olympics but they'll be sitting next to
Putin they'll be sitting next to Chi
they'll be the the leaders of powerful
Nations understand the threat of our
military is directly tied to our medal
count and Putin will fund heavily
um wrestling in Dagestan he wants those
medals he wins them but then he he feels
and you can track it historically he
feels that I can back an entire nation
down if I just show you how many Olympic
Champs I've got and he's right he's
right wow you go look at the metal count
you compare that to who's the most
feared in the world they're hand in hand
was that why this the psychology was so
different when uh when Germany law lost
the the track and field race or whatever
that was and Adolf Hitler was there and
he just was like so pissed off that this
guy came in second it's a very big deal
yes I mean you saw
you suck might be a great example heard
all those terrible that Uday Hussein
used to do to the soccer players he'd
put their legs and vice grips and you
know he thought he could just threaten
him into playing better you know he
didn't understand that it's a process
you got to start him at eight nine years
old and and really test these people out
but uh it is amazing to me a lot of
people don't know that what I just said
were the top leaders do look at the
medal count as a sign of showing their
power of their military but if you could
look at the middle count you look at the
military mites you know yeah it makes a
lot of sense right yeah it makes a lot
of sense and it also when you look at it
that way makes me
not mad at the Russian athletes for the
doping
but Russia was famously uh like excluded
from Olympic competition right they had
a big change the name they couldn't be
called Russia they were like the
athletes of the Soviet region or
something yep and they still let them in
they wouldn't you couldn't then win it
for Russia the athletes got to go but
they're on hold right now they put the
Russians on hold and they put the Bella
Russians on hold because of what's going
with this conflict in Ukraine
um you know and it hurts I mean it's
it's a really big deal those are those
are powerful they have nothing to do
with it um right I suppose that's a
conversation for another day but I'm
trying to think of the name of that and
now I can't think it's one word
yeah I'm trying to think of it
but I can't think of it either go ahead
I am
okay
we we spoke with Ariel
just before and uh yeah he heard of
Hawaii smokes marijuana no no we spoke
[Laughter]
there's still a few of us that don't
like it that would have broke in my home
we're sober guys
like all three of us uh are we've lost
our license to smoke marijuana that was
really funny
you know do you know any other Aerials
no we spoke okay
God I'm glad I uh didn't enunciate that
word
um I asked him I said do you have any
fun insights or you know questions to
ask jail and he said he said that your
wife Brittany the salt of the earth
thank you
packs your suitcase for you on every
trip it's true you have no idea what
you're gonna wear where you're going
until you open up your suitcase and find
what your wife Brittany has has packed
for you and she includes snacks and
treats that's true those original notes
in your lunchbox
for granted over time and yeah she
actually that I didn't
and I happened to be we were filming as
I was doing it so he's like well read
that note to me and uh so at any rate
yeah apparently that's not overly common
apparently I need to be more
appreciative because he's like man I've
never my wife has never packed my bag
for me let alone snacks and left me a
note so yes yeah Britney's the best and
um
and then when you get to the hotel you
never leave never
why not I don't know but that's my idea
of a good time like Brittany and I will
go to Lost vet we love Vegas we're not
Vegas people we don't like we don't
gamble or we don't have a nightlife but
just that energy to look out the window
at 3am and know you can go downstairs
and get a steak and eggs like it just
puts you in a good energy or at least it
does us so we love room service we love
uh to to rent some movies while we're
there
um she's really big into if you can get
a bathtub and then some places like
we'll even give you a robe and slippers
but that's our idea of a good time so no
I don't ever leave I get to that room I
feel like I had a great time you know
three days later but uh that's my idea
of a good time is in the room I like to
watch Netflix I like to yeah that's the
other thing that that Ariel said that
you're the only guy on Earth who still
buys a movie on the hotel room TV
yes I do I look forward to them though
that's that's a good falcos no that's
not what it's called nope nope what's
the documentary I can't believe you
can't remember him and they called the
guys yeah I'm trying to figure out about
the Russian dope and he's like oh yeah
that's me I do it yep I dope all the
Russian athletes
but some of those those guys didn't know
like I will tell you I mean that is a
very sophisticated world I I don't know
if anybody's felt more drug test than me
but the other side is I don't know if
anybody's gotten away with more drugs
than me right I mean they got me over
like seven substances but I was on at
least 17 like those tests those tests
aren't all that good well they go around
and brag we're so good it's like you
take it from me you got a lot of flaws
guys but I'll share this with you Chris
yes
one word they're saying to you as it's
very sophisticated and those guys aren't
all that sharp and you know they have
the government coming in you take this
you know just like calisthenics okay
start doing your jumping jacks here's a
handful swallow it with one hand shoot
this with the other hand I mean those
athletes really weren't they weren't in
the know can can you tell some of the
ways that people cheat drug tests
without throwing anybody under the bus
oh yeah you were that you said you were
on 17 of them and they only caught you
for seven what's this secret well
besides I don't want to say well it's
changed just over time like like
moreover yeah here would be a great
question I think this is the one that
you're you're asking me how are guys
getting away with it now yeah and right
when USANA stepped in I mean we had
Champions who the day who saw the steps
in they have never won another fight
multiple Champions that had never won
another fight you got the Incredible
Shrinking Man Who Saw the steps in all
205 Pounders are now 185 Pounders it was
very obvious I'm just sharing with you
that now it's coming back and you're
starting to see it and I was very
curious and I called some guys that were
were experts and Masters in cheating you
just got I gotta know how are they doing
it and one guy tell me he said well the
rumor is and he said but I don't believe
it he said the rumor is that they're
micro dosing where they just take this
little tiny bit and they just take it
every day and it either doesn't show up
on the test because it's so small or its
thresholds you're you're within the
limits and he said but I don't
personally believe that this is what
everybody's telling me and we can take
one look and know who's Who's Cheating
and who's not to try to get those guys
to talk or try to explain it I mean it's
it's a very competitive
it's a real Competitive Edge if you told
one guy even if it was your best retail
one guy then he tells a guy and tells it
and all of a sudden you don't have that
Advantage anymore but there there is a
number of ways to get away with it where
I'm more concerned is kind of like
you're saying with the Russians which is
I don't believe that they knew that they
were cheating I don't believe that the
athletes knew they were doing something
like that and there is examples where
where trainers or coaches can get it
into uh their athletes without the
athletes sure through their drinks
you've heard of through their Foods
you've heard of but they can also do it
with topical creams and and things like
this and I mean we've got two gyms in
this sport where every one of them not
most of them not 90 100 of their guys
from both of those gyms are in Gross
violation but they get away with it and
I always wonder okay is it do they have
real good Secrets or is somebody at a
different level
administering this and I don't know the
answer to that and that would be
speculative and that would be very uh
very dirty what I'm suggesting right now
wouldn't they get caught you would think
if they were if they were you would
think but look at the Russians didn't it
until they did yeah
that's wild yeah
and that's a big one that I just said
out there I'll just share for you
there were two gems it's 100 of the time
you look at it my God you look at all
the corner and the corner men are Juiced
out of their minds go okay you guys all
you need is really good at keeping your
mouth shut because most Fighters aren't
you could telephone Telegraph or tell a
fighter the word's gonna get out these
guys can either keep a secret or they
don't know that it's happening which is
possible
it is possible I think Secret's pretty
hard to keep yeah yeah this happened in
uh with a Turkish wrestler in 2012 and
the guy made the Olympic team and he
denied that he was cheating when usada
caught him just like everybody does but
there was something different about his
denial people go yeah that's right
that's right but where the guy goes
there's something different I I believe
him that he doesn't know so they tested
the food and they tested the drink and
they finally looked into it and he had a
trainer and the trainer used to massage
him at the end of the night oh your
shoulder all and that's it was on his
hand and he would put it in through a
substance called uh uh DMSO and dmoso is
topical it used to be for veterinarian
use only but it'll take anything on this
and it'll bring it inside right into
your veins so we would have the
testosterone and he'd have the EPO and
he'd have it mixed with the EPL let me
rub your shoulder at all and every day
he would do that and he juice this
athlete he took him from number five in
the country to number one in the world
but they caught him they got hit they
pulled his Olympic birth they found out
the trainer did it they let him go to
the Olympics after all
I'm just sharing with you that as wild
and crazy of a story as it is for me to
even suggest that somebody could be
dosing an entire team like yes 100 it's
possible and has happened I mean in back
in your day you probably fought a lot of
people on juice yes definitely and uh
[__] yeah it does make a difference oh
yeah it was part of it I mean that was
very easy to beat back then because that
you knew when the test was going to be
it wasn't a drug test it was an IQ test
at that point
um but you know now with what they do
with usada yeah now it's now it's it's
much tougher they can come and they can
come often yeah but Bellator does not
have usada is that right yep that's
right that's right and your last fight
was uh in Bellator against Tito Ortiz I
thought Machida was my last fight yeah I
followed Tito yeah but my last one was
uh gosh and it feels like yesterday but
it was years uh 2019 with Machida okay
yeah my mistake
um now at the time when you went over to
Bellator you were in the UFC still had
fights remaining on your contract and
somehow pulled off what seemingly nobody
else has you got out of your UFC
contract and into Bellator yes how did
that happen well and so it wasn't over
x i I've gotten a lot of credit for that
and I was even able to announce for both
and people like oh my God Jail's got it
figured out but there was no secret
recipe it was just hey Dana can I do
this hey Coker are you good with this
and it just it just happened to work out
but I don't know how badly
it was an interesting spot where where
Dana was kind of pulling back on some
older guys and Coker was going no those
guys are still fun and they've got some
life in them it's kind of a conflict
between the two uh organizations so
um
yeah I think it just timing wise it
worked out for me and uh you know it
doesn't it doesn't hurt when people like
you I mean that doesn't hurt to have a
friend on the other end of the phone but
right we were able to work that out uh
pretty quickly yeah pretty quickly
allowed for a good opportunity
that's Epic
um with uh I think that you had that you
saw the thing going on too which would
certainly played into it definitely yeah
I just I just ran that out I had the
deal with a suspension I think is what
you're talking about but I had just ran
that out and that was a tough one I mean
that was a real tough one for me I go
before this Commission in Nevada and
they bring in an expert witness and the
expert wouldn't and I had pled guilty I
went in there and said I'm not going to
put up a defense go ahead and punish me
did I tell you or what I mean this guy
just owns up to it mans up and takes
accountability plus we agree that
performance enhancing drugs are kind of
cool man I mean shoot I use them they're
called Bluetooth tablets they enhance my
performance and I'll have you know uh
Bluetooth tablets enhanced my
performance with Lux uh night before
last so you think jail got punished
logs got punished when I took my
Bluetooth tablet so let me just fill you
in case you're not hip to this what's a
Bluetooth tablet it's a delicious
chewable tablet that has the same active
ingredients as both Viagra and Cialis
yeah but it only costs a fraction of the
price and for the listeners of the Wild
Ride podcast yeah get a load of this
you go on bluetooth.com you use the
promo code Stevo you consult with the
medical provider right there on the
website super quick super easy
prescriptions taken care of and you got
an entire month's supply of Bluetooth
tablets absolutely for free all you
gotta pay is five bucks for shipping
believable and again like I love
Bluetooth tablets I use them I punish
Lux when I use them and you're gonna
love them too they're a really good time
so go to bluetooth.com use the promo
code Stevo enjoy a whole month's supply
of Bluetooth tablets just pay five bucks
for shipping yeah dude now let's get
back to those other performance
enhancing drugs
but it was hard because I was being
accused of legal appropriate medication
and they brought in an expert who comes
in and says the word steroid six times
and so we kind of argue and go hey wait
a minute we're not here first to and the
commission didn't understand the
difference and we even had a
commissioner say are you putting up a
defense yes if you charge us a bank
robbery or murder we're going to defend
that too we're not here for steroids
these are medications trt that's right
trt was one of them
um sure but but they actually banned trt
so then there was like clomiphene and
HCG which is what you have to do if you
come up with trt it was completely
appropriate and they they had changed
the rules so we kind of go okay fine
we're going to fall down on this but
you're saying that we're in violation of
something called water and I said this
to the room I said you're a room of
experts let me make this real simple
tell me what city wat is in and I'll sit
down and I won't stand up we're going by
water rules tell me what city they're in
I go let me make it easier you tell me
what state what is and you're the expert
that's about to punish me tell me what
Statewide is in I'll sit down I'll take
another my final offer tell me what
country what is from and to this day
they haven't answered that question and
I do bring that up it's very relevant
you tell me we're going to go off of a
set of rules from an organization that
nobody even knows what country they're
in we don't they don't have a phone
number I can't call see who's in charge
but I'm supposed to know what their
rules are that's a bunch of crap and
they said yes it's incumbent on you so
I'm the lowest form of society there is
I'm a cage fighter I'm right down there
with a prostitute and the guy
to be looked at you're the government
you're the government and you can't tell
me what city state or country they're in
but I'm supposed to know their rules
that's not right and they said well
don't you know that what you took is a
performance enhancer I said guys let me
be very clear I would never take
anything if I didn't have a reasonable
expectation that it would enhance my
performance I'm not looking to go down
I'm only taking things that enhance
performance enhancing those are positive
words right those aren't negatives and
then this guy comes in he talks about
steroids it's like I'm not here for
steroids now I'm here for legal
medications not sterile but it was I was
jammed up and they didn't understand the
difference it's a really interesting
point that you make because I've
thought that like
any athlete that you know for my
entertainment purposes I would like
their performance to be enhanced like
please enhance my
it's very weird that they acted like
that was bad it's like you guys know
what the FDA is I mean the first thing
that you have to prove the FDA is this
is make somebody better what do you mean
performing I mean how exciting was Jose
Canseco Mark McGuire
that's the only time I watched baseball
when they're smashing 600 foot dollars
and he credited something he said and he
credited something said he got it at GNC
and I was in my car I was 17. I was in
my car I was down to GNC so goddamn fast
they were all sold out it was called a
decade I can't think of what it was now
but yeah he said this is what I'm taking
and you couldn't find it it was off the
shelves but it was a lie turned out to
be growth hormone he should have just
told us yeah it's the same thing with
Lance Armstrongs like Lance just tell us
these are helpful things you're doing
something really amazing here don't lie
about it yeah John Cena rocker the liver
King who we saw a week ago it's like
guys stop lying these These are good if
you figured something out tell us maybe
we could do it yeah right you know
athletes have given it a bad name I
don't suggest that athletes do it to
cheat like I did but I'm just talking
about for every every day citizens you
know you had Stallone and uh
Schwarzenegger and Suzanne Summers all
came out 20 years ago and said estrogen
testosterone growth hormone these are
wonderful things and then you get guys
like in Lance Armstrong they're afraid
to tell Oprah like he's scared of Oprah
just say I took some growth or I never
understood that side of it the rock lies
about it to this day it's like rock what
are you doing man tell people help
people right it's like watching
Terminator 2 without him doing steroids
you're like I wouldn't watch that
athletes have given it a bad rap
athletes have get but those guys aren't
athletes they're humans and their
citizens and they're living a better
life
because like uh you know TJ dilshaw uh
fought Cody garbrand one was on one was
off and it made a difference in their
careers is that a good argument for it
yeah I think that it's fair yes yes
they're both doing it there's no excuses
that's right no it would level things
out yeah I came through it was kind of
the face of uh the testosterone era and
it was legal we were allowed to do
testosterone and it got really hard to
regulate so so one day when they just
pulled it out and said you're done but I
knew other guys that were like me but
they weren't candid like me and said
well it didn't help me anyway and it was
my hard work it's like well but let me
tell you the other side it did help me
It Made Me Stronger it helped with my
recovery it made me better that's why I
was doing it but there was something I I
don't know guys were scared to say that
they're still scared to say that and
athletes have given testosterone and
growth or met a very bad rap
show me a doctor that puts either one of
them down and that's an open challenge
find a doctor anywhere go online Dr Drew
is all about
amazing medication yeah right doctors
will tell you to be very careful to make
sure that you consult with an endic
chronologist and do it right use versus
abuse for sure I uh like have it on my
to-do list for the last like six years
to make an appointment with an
endocrinologist I just haven't gotten
around to it should I have that sounds
like a shot
48. yes 48 yeah time for me to start
yeah but they just have levels you know
you go into a blood draw and they can
show you but you use versus abuse is
very tough with human beings a human
being hey you need two
yeah
yeah right if uh what if they if they
had a pill that would cure alcoholism
we'd crush it up
that's the truth that's so funny could I
ask you about uh are you still do you
still talk to Colby Covington yes a lot
yes yes what's what's going on with him
is he gonna fight hamzat is he is going
up to middleweight the word on the
street yes that's right is that
confirmed by the way do you have that
confirm okay because I'm hearing the
same rumors yeah that's been the talk is
get Colby and Jeremiah together two best
wrestlers that's right with you yes that
Colby will do that fight but it's got to
be a number one Contender ship and that
has been something that's very unclear
where they just can't promise him that
with the thought that if Kamar uzman
regains the championship putting Colby
against Kamara third time they just
can't commit to it and Kobe's like look
if you want me to fight anybody else
fights Jeremiah and beats him they're
going to be a number you know fight for
the title you got to give me the same
thing or call somebody else and he's not
wrong to say that I mean that pot just a
little bit yeah he does deserve it he is
the clearest number one Contender that
there is but there's more to the stories
had a couple of cracks at it so but he's
a big draw too yeah you can't do
Covington newsmon three I don't think so
nobody could do Leon Edwards Covington
sure oh yeah of course yeah
sure that's happening in London oh um
yeah it's for sure I've been it wasn't
the it was a question mark whether Usman
could fight because I believe he had a
surgery on his hands on his hand but
he's apparently recovered and they're
scheduled and they're fighting in in
London
um
which is great but yeah you can't do
Covington newsmon three like a Covington
hamzat God that would be great sure
especially with Covington calling him
maybe that's got to be the funniest but
you see where that'd be frustrating if
Colby goes and finds shamayev it's gonna
be very obvious that if chimaya wins he
gets to fight for the belt so Kobe's
going with it but I gotta have the same
thing yeah um and you see what the
problem is I think you hit it on the
head which is hey you've already tried
twice we're just not gonna do a number
three I think everybody here understands
because everybody else is coming from is
there a dollar amount that it makes
sense to where it's like all right I
won't fight for the title if you offer
me yeah
okay man if
Usman 2 was a closer match than
Covington Usman won but it was not the
the first one was a very close match the
second one was not close at all so that
really ruins the three and you can't
even do three anyway when it's not a
rubber mat yeah but I agree with that
when it's not a true Trilogy Where you
flip them well can you say that Usman
does now have that you know his his
Chin's not so strong and it's a
different story after a fighter gets
knocked out like that there's an
argument there that no great promoter is
ever gonna make right yeah they're my
Champions got a compromised chin
up and buy your tickets now yeah I hear
your point though it just seems as
though and I do hope that uh live goes
to 185 I just think that's the right
move his life in general will be better
you know trying to beat that scale
that'll in careers people really don't
realize that what goes into beating that
scale the day before but I mean that
that is where the longevity of your
career starts to diminish oh that you
remind me of a question that I've asked
a number of people people what do you
think about if the inspection zone right
before you go into the Octagon where the
where the the officials putting the
Vaseline on your face what if the
inspection Zone
you were standing on a scale to reveal
how much weight you had put back on
since official weigh-ins the day of
Prior I would love that I would get a
kick out of that but would you love that
as a Fighter fighting I wouldn't mind it
as a fighter I would just say like as a
fan that's interesting to me when guys
will put that size back on that's really
interesting and some guys you'd be
stunned where some guy's Minds goes like
here let me give you an example Daniel
Cormier was getting ready to fight Steve
miocic the second time he finds out that
steepe yes uh that was Rumble Johnson
but Daniel knocks out Stipe they're
gonna do a rematch Stipe shows up he was
248 for the first fight Stephen shows up
at 2 31 for the second fight he like
went vegan and nobody could figure out
what the hell was going on I mean it
moved the line people tore their tickets
up but when word gets out to Daniel that
Stipe is going to weigh in at 231 Daniel
goes and cuts weight so Daniel's coming
in about 250 which puts him at 25 pounds
under the weight limit he didn't for
whatever reason that I do not understand
to this day he did not want the weight
scale to be that lopsided So Daniel goes
and gets in the Saun and pulls out as
much weight as he can to get closer to
Steve's weight which is a weird thing to
do
but I'm just saying that that that's the
point if guys had to get on the scale
they would do weird things that you know
numbers don't lie it makes guys behave
in a very odd Way Daniel being 25 pounds
underweight and going to Asana to get
closer to his opponent because there was
a rumor that he was coming in like
that's weird but he did it but he did it
he's a normal guy and he did it so those
numbers man they make people do weird
stuff that'd be a kick if they got in
right before the yeah right right there
and a lot of people have asked I asked
DC uh Bruce Buffer that's first like
like nobody's with me on that sure it's
you and me I think they're not with you
in the terms of are you gonna get a
commission to sanction that and actually
do it would it be interesting from an
audience perspective yes it's
fascinating what guy's way on Fight
Night is is very fascinating how much I
mean what's the most extreme you've ever
seen somebody blow up after a weight
like uh you know how much weight they
put back on again 20 pounds oh for sure
yeah there's been 85 Pounders that have
weighed uh 207 the next day you know 185
one day and 207 but I gotta remind you
this is back when IVs were loud so you
know you go to your room and get IV and
get get rehydrated and you know some of
that 15 and 20 pounds would come uh
really quickly and easily they don't do
that now so you know you're close why
can't you do IVs uh 12 to 15. they they
banned them a great way to flush illegal
drugs is to then just run an IV so if
you were to take performance enhancers
this was the Lance Armstrong method then
hook up to an IV and flush that through
your system then the testing agents can
come and you'll you'll be clear so we
started to get ahead of that just banned
uh IVs it's like drinking a gallon of
water before you take a drug test maybe
but that never works people always like
you know the drinking the vinegar juice
before a drug test I got I got caught
with taking a drug test in high school
with uh pee in my pocket out of the old
apple juice things and the lady was like
what's that I'm like what's what and
she's like ding ding ding and I'm like a
[__] I'm sorry
where'd you buy that by the way like the
internet no no it was just like one of
those Martinelli's apple juice okay you
know they look like an apple yeah and I
peed in it and I took it into a drug
test sure no I go is your own pizza my
buddy's pee that I was sitting there all
right and I was trying to get a job at
PetSmart cleaning fish tanks nice and I
failed the drug tests
I had a drug test
um when I was 19 years old that I was
gonna have to take and so I'd like drank
a gallon of water and uh fell asleep my
friend's soap and peed on the sofa
because I drank too much water like you
put a pube in the thing and it
contaminates the test you can't take it
is that like uh one other thing about uh
that I'd like to see
um we're watching the UFC fights without
fail every time tail of the tape you
know introducing the fighter we see the
odds going into the fight you know we
know the the oddsmakers favor
um sometimes it's actually pretty rare
going into a round two or around three
they'll show the live odds and how the
odds have fluctuated since the beginning
of the fight
I would like to see as a rule the
beginning of every subsequent round all
the time show the live odds and how they
fluctuate sure I I just want to know
that that's the closest thing we get to
open scoring and uh not that I'm saying
open scoring is great but as a fan I'm
always very interested to see the odds
and and I'm even more interested to see
how they're changing during the fight I
think that's interesting too I I enjoyed
watching the uh the last presidential
election but they were showing that like
as the states were coming in the odds
were moving all over but that changed it
I mean it does change something as a fan
numbers don't lie so anytime you can get
those numbers like what you're
suggesting it does add to it what do you
think of open score by the way ah
there's an argument that place right
there's an argument that you get people
coasting through fights it makes fights
more boring sure you know
um better to you always want your
cornermen to tell you that you are
losing sure sure and to have official
knowledge that you are not losing is not
good for the fans yeah I agree with that
and there is a massive excitement at the
end of the night when you don't know and
Bruce Buffer makes the announcement it's
it's a big deal and you would be taking
that away and uh I know a lot of
commissions are looking at doing that
Damon Scott Coker against it and I think
that that should be the final say not
commissions not athletes not any but the
promoters who have to find a way to make
this profitable are saying this hurts
the product don't do it I think that
they really need a respect needs to be
shown and so far it has been but it
would change it I mean there is
something that is is compelling about
that I think the showing live odds as a
rule is the compromise that makes
everybody happy sure they do it anyway
sometimes so you can't argue about uh
whether you can do it or not yeah do
they do it in any other sports
um you know in other sports betting odds
are a little bit taboo to to acknowledge
like you'll never see it in football
that's right when you were fighting were
you looking at your odds I was not but
that's an interesting point that you
make yeah they don't really do that in
football we got in front of it I think
that they'll catch up but you're right
about that uh no I never was not not
when you were actually in there but I
was so exhausted in there it is such a
tiring sport I came from wrestling you
worked every single day just to be able
to go six minutes with another guy and
hold up he's going hard here going hard
then you get into this and it's 25
minutes I mean it was just it was so
tiring I only bring that up because you
asked if I was looking at the odds I
wanted to known where to look and if I
saw him I wouldn't know what they meant
like it is in such a a zone of Every
Breath You know every drink of water
just trying to to get another beat I
would have been able to calculate it if
I looked up and so I wouldn't know what
it meant I gotta go deal with this guy
it was different the wrestling match
were trying to score points that you
know fight the guy's trying to damage
you it's it's different there's nowhere
to stall there's no no way to eat up
clock in a fight yeah very different
very nerve-wracking in that in that
regard
yeah back to Kobe Covington yeah we I
love Coldplay dude he's fantastic I've
said this so so often that I'm just
so invested in disliking him sure he's
just he he's he's
masterful at making you dislike him and
then and like with Jake Paul within
anybody who's uh in this digital age
it's it doesn't matter if it's positive
attention or negative attention it's
just attention is the most valuable
commodity known to man Colby Covington
is masterful like getting attention
albeit very negative attention
um you being
the original
trash talker guy you know like you were
the first like right I mean was there a
a prolific trash talker in MMA before
you no no that was an art that you uh
brought over from from wrestling for
sure yeah and since you like clearly
McGregor was the you know became the
prolific trash talker
I mean uh again it's effective I'll
never miss a call because sure I mean
I'll never miss any fight I'm I'm uh I'm
addicted to to the sport
um but uh what are your thoughts just
about trash talk in general like
yeah and I I have my I have my own views
on it um but but I had a code and I
stuck fiercely to the code I was called
by Sports illustrator the biggest [__]
talker in All Sport but I had never used
a four-letter word never you'll never
find anything public written or audio
I've never used a profanity and that was
one of the things I would never want to
after anybody unless they were in front
of me if I ever did go after somebody I
would always show up whether I felt good
or not I would I would go to that ring
and answer for it so I mean I just had I
had my own little code and I had two
different jurisdictions uh threatened to
not give me a license I had a guy named
Kaiser out of Nevada who said that uh
that I am not an example for little kids
and I was really thinking of going Keith
I've never used a bad word like you've
got what are you what are you talking
about but yes because of my my trash
talking and I only say it because it
wasn't all that bad it was just it was
the first it was way ahead of the time
for its time and it did catch people off
guard it was just a meaningfully a
difference opinion A lot of people
thought that respect was about bowing to
someone's face and put a knife in their
back when they turned around I will tell
you to your face I'm gonna put a knife
in your back when you turn around and
there's a big difference
but I thought mine was more honorable so
you know you reach for years and I'll
reach for one let's see who's fastest
but there's no sense in hiding this and
you know I appreciate that about Colby I
know that his is a little bit different
and he is a little bit rougher at times
but I do appreciate that that he can
take the booze and if you're a heel if
you're the bad guy Boos are a heels
cheers and you don't have very many
heels because they can't take the booze
they say they want it they want the
checks they want the placement on the
car but they can't take the heat they
just can't they can't take it in their
real life you know these are I'm a tough
guy they're not all that tough they're
really sensitive and Colby's able to
take he's able to take the hits and
someday he will be looked back on and
people appreciate what he did but for
right now it's probably a pretty lonely
path
man that that that's so rad that's so
well said
um man it was kind of like when we had
Ronda Rousey on the podcast it made
headlines and it was negative headlines
and then we called her like [__] is that
and she's like dude are you kidding me I
love this [__] I'm the heel sure like
the more the merrier you know and it was
like a different perspective like oh
[__] like there's levels remember that
well I was like oh man gosh like I
didn't want to bummer out there's
backfire on you and [__] and she's like
are you kidding me I'm [__] gardening
making headlines yeah yeah
it's fantastic man so what's next for a
channel
soon to be can I throw one at you guys
that uh car McGregor I I am a bit of an
advocate for Conor I feel like I'm in a
big brother role where he goes and does
something I have to come and explain it
to the audience but he took such a bad
rap in his last fight just to remind you
guys he he breaks his way right there
yeah he's down on the canvas Joe Rogan's
down you know interviewing him and
Connor's yelling about it you know the
wife somebody slipping in my DMs so
people tell you know what a jerk he was
and what a bad guy and I said okay maybe
maybe that's what you saw or maybe you
just saw a performer so committed to
entertainment that even broken in half
before they faded a black and rolled the
credits he gave you everything that you
tuned in for and more you know there you
might not understand where the real
Masters are at work here and you know if
you don't see that you want a blue guy
you want to hate a guy go ahead but
there's also something that I think that
you should appreciate I don't know which
one it was maybe Conor was showing us
the real him and maybe he's a real jerk
but maybe he's not and maybe he was so
committed to the performance that he
played it until you know until the ship
went down and I think that that should
be considered because I hear Ron I know
people like to say the right things Iran
is at home crying herself to sleep none
of that stuff's real you just try to let
her know Rhonda these are good things
these are positive and good things and
every now and then you'll get her to
come and repeat it well I created an
emotion and that's like no but it really
is f them if they're booing it doesn't
matter if if they like you or they don't
like you is good if they have if they're
indifferent for you you have a problem
and I know that some of the heels can
come out and repeat that but they don't
actually mean it they're at home crying
in a bottle of wine and that that's much
more the real Rhonda the real masters of
their craft are the ones like Colby
that'll sit there with a broken leg and
finish this thing out
yeah
um well are there rules to being the
heel because people were like you don't
you don't say anything about you know
his wife or then Kobe and uh Jorge mask
with all he brought up the kids or
George around jail George is
it Jorge officially because I want to be
right is it Jorge I'll switch to Jorge
are there rules that you should stay in
or is it all uh uh you know no holds
bars when it comes to trash talking I
just think whatever I I think if you're
going to be an anti-hero one of the
things that that all great anti-heroes
will have is they will have a code it
won't be society's codes it won't be
laws it won't be a normal person's code
but it will be a code and they will
fiercely adhere to the code now this is
the art of the bad guy not very many
people are good bad guys and this
includes in Hollywood not very many
people are good at being a bad guy but
if you're going to be a good bad guy
you've got to have a code you've got to
advertise through the audience what it
is and you must fiercely adhere to it no
matter what you must defend it with an
honor that's the kind of guy that's the
kind of a heel that the crowd will get
behind to be a cool heel is the most
guaranteed monetizable box office that
you can have that would be the rock that
would be Stone Cold Steve Austin by
example to be a bad guy and be a cool
bad guy and most don't understand that
because they never lay out what their
code is and if you're if you've got a
code and you're a bad guy so you're
telling Society I don't need to follow
your rules here's a better set of rules
you've got to advertise what it is and
if you go off script and at no point in
there was going after a kid's family or
his child if that wasn't part of your
code mode then you've broken your own
rules and now you're not just a you're
not a bad guy you're a bad guy and
there's a difference are you gonna
follow your own code as governor oh yes
you already have it written out oh
heavens yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes things will be very different I I
don't believe you know if you if you
were to go through Oregon I think what
you would find would be a a gross
misrepresentation we have a couple of
pockets uh that sway the vote you know
when the non-producers
outvote The Producers you have a problem
and and that's what we have in Oregon
we're we're going to weed that out okay
good all right I have no choice
Governor so now people got here the
store of the Oregon Trail is a very well
known story and it wasn't told by people
with piercings in their nose and purple
hair it was told by Good Old Boys a road
here with a pistol in their hip to
protect their family that's who Oregon
really is we're not these people that
well Norman County some of these others
try to try to make us and if we are
we're gonna find out because I'm going
to test that theory you're going to be
like the John Dutton of Oregon yes
that's right that's right I love it I
like that too and he only said one thing
that I really appreciated which is he
said I am the opposite of progress I am
the opposite of progressive I love it
yes yes we will not be going in that
direction John Dunn what do you what do
you think of that you know they made a
big mistake in the last one so the girl
Beth okay she gets mad at her brother
yeah
because the brother reveals the train
station now in the season finale last
year she met him at the train station to
take the photo to blackmail him how did
she know she didn't follow him there she
was waiting for him there she knew they
made a big mistake yeah Taylor shared
and screwed that one up that's smart are
you watching mayors of Kingston I'm not
best show on TV really oh yeah I love
Yellowstone but it's drastically yeah
Yellowstone yes very good I like 1932 I
mean I appreciate all of those I don't
like this this new mid-season break you
know you got you got 10 episodes gonna
see if they're gonna do five and then
we're gonna come back for another five
that is such a middle finger to the
audience yeah episodes and then they
have eight more coming in right May
right season break that's a middle
finger to the audience and I I really
think that that's wrong but mayor of
Kingstown is the best show on TV that I
will tell you Mary Kingston what's that
on that's on Paramount plus okay yes
there you go are you subscribed to
Paramount yes
jackass is uh Paramount Pictures Viacom
okay they
did this thing where the movie comes out
and without uh bringing the movie to uh
Netflix or you know any like a market
comparison you know to establish its
value no they just sold it to themselves
to stream jackass Forever on Paramount
plus which uh like one would argue is uh
is not legal and uh they did the same
thing with Tom Cruise's movie uh the
Maverick Maverick and then there's
another movie there's three potential uh
litigations wow
I'm just pissed they didn't give me a
free login
S three or more right somebody will take
that case yeah I love it right all right
you want to know the great class action
coming up can I tell you one more thing
so people come back okay now let me
think about this Colin Kaepernick okay
so Colin Kaepernick goes and takes a
knee the NFL doesn't know what the hell
they're gonna do so they all get
together and go here's what we're gonna
do we're going to boot him so we have to
deal with it but none of you pick him up
deal deal okay great so he's out of the
league he finds out is that confirmed no
okay oh no no you can't confirm it
because he did a very quiet deal which
is guesstimated to be worth about 70
million dollars where the league got
together because that's highly illegal
to do and they had to pay him off okay
great now no you can't I cannot confirm
it this is what's believed to have
happened oh great what you need to
understand is you you've got this uh
gender movement going on through the
NCAA right now but what what what people
need to realize is nobody has been
recruited and given a scholarship where
they were a boy and then a girl or a
girl and the boy that's only happening
once they're in college with this
college and then they make the switch
and that's very relevant that you know
that because at some point the exact
same people are for the exact same
reasons that they came after the NFL and
Kaepernick are going to come after the
NCAA and they're going to say how are
you giving the number three girl a
scholarship when she lost by five
seconds to the and you didn't give her a
scholarship and at some but this is how
the ncaa's handle it right now the way
they're handling this this massive what
do we do is don't scholarship them don't
but somebody is going to call them on
that and when they do the floodgates
they're going to open and what you know
is women are not going to get
scholarships anymore it's going to be
it's going to be a very interesting spot
is that old adage be careful of what you
ask for because you just might get it
but that's the Miss that's the Miss
right now and the NCAA thinks that
they're doing this quietly like people
aren't watching they are watching you
know I'm the one that busted Stanford
did you know that I didn't CLP Sunny I'm
the one that did the standard admissions
Scandal 100 okay yeah they drop up the
wrestling program and I knew why they
had dropped the program and I came and I
went public with it on on my YouTube and
I said this is what you guys are doing
you guys are so knee-deep that you're
trying to get rid of all the sports that
have been bought and paid for that's
illegal and I said like bring wrestling
back or else we're going to play it the
other way and they brought wrestling
back and nobody really credited me only
a few people have ever created yeah okay
but I'm telling you right now that that
this is the problem the ncaa's got they
think they're getting away with it
you're not gonna get away with it help
me understand how that applies to the
Kaepernick situation so the Kaepernick
situation with the NFL did they didn't
know how to handle uh this cultural
outcry of him taking the knee some
support it and some against they didn't
know what to do so they all jump on the
phone all the owners they go San
Francisco look we're going to cut him
but none of you guys pick him up let's
just get him out of here we don't have
this knee thing anymore and we can move
on with football so that's what they did
which is highly illegal to do you can't
do price fixing you can't do things like
this you can't be a monopoly you also
can't interfere with the contractual
agreement I mean they broke a number of
federal laws they got caught and they
paid him 70 million allegedly paid him 7
million dollars so uh and but you have
to understand I mean Kaepernick is a
Nike athlete which is sitting about 20
miles behind us Beaverton Oregon so I
mean when I'm saying allegedly I'm
saying that to be polite this is exactly
what happened okay but I tied that in
because the NCAA is running that same
shell game does the 70 million come from
uh yes the league the league of San
Francisco no no the league itself yeah
okay yes but I but I bring the two
because the exact same thing is going on
with the NCAA they don't know how to
handle this they don't know what to do
so if you get there on a scholarship and
then you make the switch great we'll
praise you if we can we'll hide you if
we can do that we're talking about
giving the scholarship to uh a male who
when the mail arrives at the University
becomes a female and has a an advantage
over the other females because what
we're talking about is dramatically a
man the only folks in the NCAA that are
are testing this Theory of transgender
the only folks that are testing that are
people that were already there that's
the point that I'm trying to make
they're not getting recruited in you're
not signing women that used to be uh
playing as males and and that's how
they're trying to handle this and
eventually they're going to get called
out how often does this like happening
because you only hear about the swimmer
yeah but is this happening a lot more
than we're seeing no no it's very
infrequent yeah I mean the door is open
to it's very infrequent but eventually
you're going to get a head coach in
there that just wants to win eventually
you're going to put somebody like me in
there or if I could have five women in
their national champions or I could have
five men that have never ever done the
sport but they're willing to say they
feel like women today I'm going to take
them and I'm going to win the Nationals
yeah eventually you're going to have
people like me they're they're just
going to come out and they're vicious
and hungry for victory and that hasn't
happened yet this is the ncaa's way of
trying to silence them but these
attorneys are gonna there is that
there's that Instagram we're together
where this like bodybuilder identified
as woman for the day and just set every
single record for weightlifting yes
funny but then at what point do you
you're gonna draw the line because it's
going to start happening sure well but
it did go all the way up to the Olympic
Games and people thought it would be
flooded with that and it wasn't thank
goodness but you know Dana White's had
to deal with that where he goes you know
what guys would do to be in the UFC if
they if they could cut their dick off
and get a contract but they would you
know don't don't put me in that spot
and he's right to say that I mean it it
really is a very uh tough position and
the way the NCAA is handling it instead
of stepping forward and wanting to be
cultural Warriors is they think they're
gonna they're gonna do this quietly
which they did until today when I just
called them out which is the same thing
I did at Stanford you can go and Trace
that I am the one that broke the
Stanford admission scandals and I got
wrestling back and nobody's thanked me
the Stanford was with Lori Laughlin when
she went to jail and she's one of them
yeah you put Uncle Becky in jail yeah
mother of the Year by the way mother of
the year that was like performance
enhancing Dr of course they're here to
enhance your performance of course a
good mother is going to pull strength
what do you think networking is that's
precisely how it works when I take my
hot ass wife to a restaurant in New York
and I gotta wait in line there's no line
for me why because when I shook the
major D's hand there was 500 in it
that's the way this world works if you
don't have the 500 you sit in the line
if you do and you know the system you
get your kid in a Stanford not to
mention they cheated to get into USC
what is you you nobody cheats to get
into USC USC is a worthless degree you
cheat to get into Princeton you cheat to
get into Harvard Stanford even USC
that's what Aunt Becky did you know USC
stands for no University of spoiled
children sure I could I could see that
but why would you brag about getting
into USC that was a little bit weird in
all fairness if her kids weren't good
enough to get into USA it's a little
Pepperdine you know you sprinkle the
cheese around USC yeah I think Snoop
Dogg's boys went to USC if I remember
right come on yeah all right
uncle chal uncle Jill I wanna
uh with us who doesn't
appreciate or know about your YouTube
yes please don't to get on there you're
you're prolific we love your car it's
very sweet of you yeah come on man and
uh
I'm remiss I don't know about a channel
son and Instagram I gotta get on there
is it yeah I got an Instagram yeah I
would give the address if I knew it but
I imagine it's Chael Sonnen I mentioned
that the Twitter's Channel by the way
what do you think of Twitter now you
like what elon's doing uh I didn't think
that to me Twitter is only for trying to
get on the screen during the fights sure
yeah sure I I don't have an opinion
about Twitter beyond that I will tell
you what I find most interesting about
Twitter is that Elon Musk came in and
fire 70 and my Twitter works just the
same so what in the hell were those
people doing I mean how do you come in
on day one and fire 70 and the app
doesn't change at all kind of
interesting well I read that like you
know all the layoffs in the big text now
they're they're following suit and so
are they following suit because not
because of Twitter well that's one of
the things like stocks were overvalued
but they saw what Elon the question is
is it because the stocks are overvalued
or is it because they saw what Elon did
and it didn't make a damn difference
because they saved a lot of money it's
got a lot more to do with uh the stock
price collapsing on its own without
anything to do with Twitter or Elon Musk
that's just the what's going on with the
economy that's what's going on with the
stock market
overvalued balloon pop sure I know what
you're talking about though Google
Google is the one to read Microsoft yeah
they all laid off tens of thousands
Salesforce Google said you never have to
come back by the way said you never you
can all be remote work and I mean that
just doesn't work in all fairness you
can see where that'd be annoying and
there's nothing you can do on your
bottom line there's nothing to enhance
profits faster for any company it
wouldn't matter if it's your mom coffee
shopper
all the way up to Google then turn the
fat that's right then to take a good
look at payroll oh I was in Portland
last night I went to a coffee shop and
had a robot yeah I'm doing the coffee
where are we in Portland that's awesome
or something yeah
[Music]
with the tassels on yeah yeah now it's
quite an experience only in Oregon yeah
not not in one year governor no
when the pandemic by the way and all
these Oregon they all hid out from the
boogie monster coronavirus which is
another thing we're going to test when
I'm Governor but uh they did not those
those businesses thrived they still
showed up down there because it was just
one person they were separated oh there
was a line around the corner so are you
going to keep them or get rid of them
when you're Governor because that's
gonna make that's gonna sway my butt yes
the naked Baristas yes they will stay I
had something else to cover with you we
got onto Elon Musk you know you're
trying to rush me ever since ever since
I got here
Tom Brady came out they were holding the
parade because he retired I worked for
ESPN I come he said he's not going to
read he's going to play next year oh by
the way him and his wife are splitting
up I told the world this I got no credit
for it I thought that it was very
frustrating and I'm telling you right
now what they did with Kaepernick is
gonna go down with the NCAA and I do I
do want that recognized the NCAA needs
to be called out if they want to be
wimps about this and they don't want to
step forward they need to know they're
going to eventually find themselves in a
class action lawsuit you've got to be
giving scholarships out if you're going
to contest this it's a very big deal
what I'm telling you guys right now very
big deal
you know what come to think of it I
really don't have anything else to talk
to you about my Twitter I hope your show
goes well thank you for the refills by
the way there's nothing uh personal
about it we just didn't we normally go
about an hour that's the only thing
we're an hour and a half in all right
we're an hour and a half in yeah
it's great I absolutely loved it I love
uh I'm a fan I enjoyed
I'm a fan I was fascinated the entire
time and and uh I would hate for you to
feel that uh that that wasn't the case I
enjoyed it I loved it and um thank you
for for letting us come to you man I
appreciate you guys this is awesome my
favorite chill moment in the history is
uh when you're like I'm not gonna let
you get any closer I can't let them get
close you can't let him I know the same
thing about fighting that you all know
about fighting which is whatever your
father told you and my dad's thing was
not let let them throw the first punch
like everybody else my dad's thing was
as soon as they're within Arm's Reach
the fight has begun do not let them get
with an army if you have a problem with
someone and they get within Arm's Reach
it has begun I I if I had children I
would have them watch that to to say
this is what a person does if they
encroach on your personal space yes I
thought that was very man I like this
group of guys I mean just to share
that they don't know who they were
born as good as planned as I was and
they're trying to sit while he hit all
of us and we never hit him well you
stepped within the space what'd you come
over for you saw me and this guy getting
into it and you chose to go I was behind
a door and I was over here you're
telling the story it's like guys as much
as I appreciate the The Stretch
Armstrong Bruce Lee that you're you're
making me my arm's this long you either
here or you weren't you were all walked
up on this or you didn't so did you or
not did I come to you or did you come to
me well we came to you well you came to
me looking for problems you just didn't
know who you were playing with so don't
don't do that stuff to me you take an
ass whoop and you gotta take it like a
man sometimes so for the record
Beyond This Is the personal space yes
she lets you get close right okay I
can't trust you stay back stay back but
you can only back up so far right back
up so far then sometimes you got you got
to go forward yeah what if they're just
coming into for a handshake yes
they should declare that's where the
handshake comes from yeah and so you're
you know you're not reaching for the
sword yeah sure yeah it's as old as time
all right what if you're coming for a
handshake
you'd feel pretty bad about that all
right
how do we wrap this what do we do we say
goodbye thank you thank you so much
I genuinely hope that he was just
kidding right what he's like
suggesting that uh that I was being rude
I wasn't trying to be rude man love this
guy love Shale and uh I think
I think he likes me too
but I'll tell you I don't love anybody
more than I love my street team that
like I'm on tour all the time people
come up to me street team means the
world to me and if you're a new listener
you don't know what the street team is
when this podcast started I asked the
listeners who made it all the way to the
end I said you guys who made it all the
way to the end are the most important
people to me and I want to give love to
the guests so if you can screenshot like
the podcast and post it tagging me and
the guest just to let them know that you
enjoyed the time with them that's like
the Grassroots promotion the street team
the people out there putting it out
there that they love the Wild Ride
podcast and uh I love everything about
that I'm glad I came up with that and
I'm and I love you guys who do that
maybe give a little love to jail let him
know Stevo
Stevo doesn't want you to think he was
rude Steve loves you bro yeah and I love
you even more thank you